il a fait le tour du monde en dansant
avec d'autres personnes handicapées luca
patuelli surnommés les illégaux a fondé
il y a dix dans une troupe dont le
mantra est pas d' excuses pas de limites
avec n'est pas la différence daf ans
luca patuelli est né avec une maladie
musculaire qui touche les articulations
de ses jambes
à 15 ans il découvre le breakdance avec
ses béquilles toute ma passion pour la
danse le pousse à participer à soyaux
think you can dance canada
il se retrouve même à l'émission d'
ellen degeneres
mais c'était incroyable c'était vraiment
bien d'un coup c'était un rêve d'une
culture
en plus des compétitions internationales
luca patuelli donne des cours de danse à
des gens ont besoin particulier dans des
locaux des grands ballets canadiens une
mission de l'organisation pouvoir
toucher aussi dans une façon un peu plus
intime en public et peut-être abidjan
des ouïes danser mais parfois pas
nécessairement sur scène je veux que les
jeunes se sentent comme les superstars s
appuie alors cette dame la confiance
comme ça quand les gens sort du studio
vont être fiers dans la marche a dit mme
pierre louis cane et pour la toute
première fois samedi
il participera à un événement et pop qui
aura lieu dans les locaux des grands
ballets des jeunes avec un handicap
seront jumelés à des professionnels de
la danse
je crois que la danse c'est la liberté
n'importe quel âge qu'elle fasse quel
sexe qu'elle habilité quelqu'un tout le
monde peut danser la danse a poussé luca
patuelli à se dépasser
il est maintenant lui-même une source
d'inspiration
ici julie jacquemond boudreau radio
canada montréal
[Musique]